Hey, I'm Brandon I'm Evan. And welcome to our episode on mountain gamers.
But first here's a message from our sponsor. That's right.
A big shout out to manscape for sponsoring this episode,
you have heard us talk about the lawn mower 3.0 the best darn ball trimmer
on the market. Spoiler alert. You could also use it on your face,
but I want to tell you today about fall theater industry. That's right.
Baldy on wait, do we need that? Well,
your crotch is basically just like armpits for your legs.
So given that it's also [inaudible] and moisturizing.
Why not just slap some on there? It's paraben-free it is sulfate free.
No dyes. It's gentle on your skin.
There's access the age control and you're going to love this it's vegan.
That's vegan. Indeed.
It is go to manscape.com/jubilee to get 20% off plus free shipping
instantly a at checkout, no promo code needed. Wow. That was really educational.
I totally have to get that well, without further ado,
here's our episode on men gamers.
We brought together six professionals. I'm a pro gamer. I play Tekken seven.
I am a professional gamer. I am a pro gamer. I am a pro gamer.
I am a pro one is a liar.
If the group discovers who the liar is, they'll win a cash prize.
If the liar survives,
they win the cash prize with Mike's and camera's off and fake gamer
aliases. Can they find the odd man out?
I am coming into this pretty confident that we're going to come out.
My game plan going into this is I really don't have one.
Well,
I'm going to be confident about me being a gamer because I am just going to try
to exude that confidence about it.
A lot of liars in the gaming industry throughout my career.
So I'm going to be able to find them I'm the last.
Person people would guess at them all. I'm like, yeah.
Dude,
I feel kind of nervous that I'm just going to get voted out on the first round.
Hopefully you don't seem too sketchy to people.
I don't want to get eliminated at first. Dig it. Okay.
I really hope that my what's popping gamers is going to attract too much
attention. I don't want to say the first thing probably going to be like,
what do you guys play? And I play smash. Okay.
Super smash brothers league of legends, both good proteins.
I'll tell type rocket league. Alright. Oh, smash.
Okay. CS Valor. And we got rocket league.
Okay. This, this, this chick says that she plays Hearthstone.
I used to be pro Hearthstone player.
So kind of have an idea of that scene. Sweet.
I, I mean, of course, you know,
everybody's naming something that is in a fighting game. Of course.
Credit saying that I'm from mainly gives me a lot of credit.
Uh, it's just nuts.
It's like we trained the Himalayas 10,000 years and to be sports things,
there's like common cities. I want to see what people maybe.
Probably Montreal for DreamHack.
Even city. We there's only so, Oh wait.
Oh, what favorite.
City you've been to? Um.
Greenland's feel like
this. I feel.
Ah. I'm not really sure. Okay. The league of legends player,
I'm the little suss of that because it's just so easy to say league of legends.
Oh my God. That round is so fast.
Nobody mentioned a fighting game. I got too anxious.
Although I was more thinking out loud than I was typing.
Hopefully that doesn't hurt me,
but I definitely did vote for J dizzle because less info given by Dave Bizzle.
I'm probably going to vote for banana just because I don't know who
else to vote for.
I wouldn't say it. Hey, are you into pro gaming?
I'm going to vote for a lobster. I think lost watch. There's a little sauce.
Wow. I guess maybe I look kind of sauce. Gotta be banana,
but I gotta go with J bezel. Honestly, she was not talking much fudge, dude.
I really hope that I feel like I was the most suspicious.
I'm looking at this objectively and I feel like I was the most suspicious,
I guess Jay Bizzle. Why not?
The first person eliminated in round one is
J Bez. Gosh,
I made it through round one thing. My minute is rough. I'm curious to see why.
Good luck charm.
I'm putting my ritual. Like what I do.
Um.
There's something really specific about the data protection. Seven
technique.
No fireballs magic is a super dope team
back there.
Um, okay. Some kind of high level strategy that I got to talk about. I mean,
I don't want to mention wave dashing because that's kind of obvious
aerial interrupts.
I mean it's true. No, one's good at magic and the scope of the game. No,
one's actually good. On-site of Elron CLG. Oh. Oh, that's pretty.
That's pretty crazy one CLG right now. Woof. Wow.
Wait, what does Larry play? Ghana.
Back down, back for a second guys. Okay. So we're getting technical here.
I'm on CLG right now. Maybe we know here.
I think I know Greenland's herd. Is it hugs? Is it Hugo?
I think I know what that person is.
I have been unsigned and Valor, but played for CLG.
When I played in CS currently playing as prospects in invalid.
What does that mean? Does that as prospects?
That's I don't know what that means. Okay. I think I know Greenland.
Yes. I'm safe. Okay. Did they have an idea of who this is? Okay.
Um, gaming outlets
or what
G-Force experience. Okay. You all one?
I don't know. I'm asking about price.
I was in between late 2017 and most of the 2018 for me. All right.
I'm a little sense of BRN. Um,
you like, okay. Bananas talking about liking combo decks.
Okay.
Oh, this is so, Oh, I'm not voted out.
Oh my God.
I think I'm good. Actually. Do I have to vote for someone?
Honestly, green lantern is kind of sus I kind of got to go with Greenland.
They did not really talk too much. Okay. Well I'm pretty sure BRN is,
which is good vibe banana. I'm going to say Apple cat,
just because like their high level technique doesn't really seem so high level.
I'm gonna go with Larry. Larry, the lobster.
For B R N. I I don't care if I look stupid after this video, I am so sure.
It's BRN.
So the result of Brown two was a five-way
split. Every single person got one boat.
I called it before it happened. That means I got voted on.
Are we.
Supposed to do in this power?
You have to take a look.
Yeah. I honestly don't know.
It is so difficult to tell what anybody is right now. It is such a fast round,
ah, fudge dude.
[Inaudible]
I'm going to start using this is man. I really can't tell. I play. What's good.
That's literally the correct answer for a pro player. Kind of. Okay.
What am I supposed to do? Is there more shade on me? I don't understand Larry.
I like.
13.
I forgot us a lot of details. BRN still not saying much
Ruined names. Some big name wins.
I'm going to get them to start saying this big game. Big name wins.
Uh, alums, uh, uh,
um, laughing duck.
Nobody going? Nobody said anything. Okay.
I did not expect this to happen. I am helpless. And so unsure.
I can't believe someone voted for me. I feel kind of bad going after Panetta.
Larry doesn't know anything about car games. And so,
and so that's why they're throwing shade on me. Like any specifics?
What do you mean banana has been legit,
like responding last to everything. I don't know. I gotta go banana.
I want them on my thing to be around because applicant is getting really
specific. Gotta be banana. If it's not. I'm sorry, banana.
If you're watching this video, I humbly apologize to you,
Ty. Is
it wasn't me? It wasn't me. I do think bird was way too vague.
Oh man. I thought we had that. Larry. I thought we were good.
I, 100% believe the molds banana.
We're going to turn on Mike's.
And everybody will get to interact with each other via audio as they play.
Definitely biased towards the fighting game players. By the way.
No, I don't think so. Cause I'm playing on a keyboard.
Wait, did I just kill myself? Who am I?
And my game is so loud that I'm having trouble hearing, but um,
turn your games on off. We could all just like stand still for a second.
I want to win. Wait. No, but,
but we could all stop for a second so you can turn your names on. Yeah,
let's all. Let's all stop. We can be settled here.
I think I accidentally jumped off and killed myself.
Okay. So you do a tournament out in Bangkok, Thailand. What was the tournament?
Did you get your sound controlled freelancer? What? Oh,
I'm asking, uh, what was the tournament called that you went to in Thailand?
We were, we were waiting for you to, um, get your sound. I'm like, Oh no,
it's cool. I can hear it. It's fine. Yeah.
It wasn't that it was for the second world four finals and they had something
called the last chance off people who get it,
get the points to actually make it.
So that's why I went there for the final two lashes qualifier.
And they ended up how'd you place it in?
I got 33rd in the last I bought by her last year.
It was a class. Remember who you lost him?
Yes. His name is you and he's a thing way player from Japan. Okay.
All. Oh, um, Larry. Okay. How do I, how do we know that?
You're not like just an LCS coach and streamer as opposed to like a player?
Like how can you distinct yourself?
Um, you know, honestly, I don't know.
And anyone could just be someone who's really knowledgeable in this scene. Well,
I guess apparently not you guys since apparently, you know each other, but uh.
Well, I, I only know, uh, um, banana,
but Apple sounded real convincing to me, but Larry, I'm just wondering,
what was the last tournament you answered? Like what was it?
Uh, well, I'll see you us is more like based, right?
So you only qualify for tournaments if you do really well on the Susan, the last
four time TL and real championship, where are you in the last? Uh,
and funny. What was the last time you played it? Yeah, 2018. My last land.
Dude, I haven't hit it like a gear stuff, stuff jumping around. Let me hit you.
So for a month before that we got knocked out in group stages,
even though we went three and three sucks.
Really try not to curse too much because like they want this footage, right.
My bad, sorry, Jubilee. Um, but yeah,
after that, sorry. So.
The last time it was for team looking at 2018.
Worlds and before that was kind of PSI
mid-season invitation and all that was in Berlin.
And that one sucked because we had to play all our scrims in the hotel.
And for some reason there's no air conditioning in the hotels.
So we were just screaming and like 95 degree heat and everyone was screaming,
shirtless because it was so hot.
Playing games without air conditioning is like.
I'm like all the computers in the room and it's really hot,
really hot or he'd wait, that was it.
Wait, this was the first time we told somebody, okay, we gotta, we gotta get.
The round. Just ended it.
It looks like green lantern and banana know each other.
So I guess my best chance of survival would be to vote for Apple cat.
I definitely think the odd man.
Apple cat was very specific. If I have to vote for anybody,
it's going to be Larry applicant seems pretty convincing. I mean,
I know green lantern is we're friends. And so if we get a majority vote in,
then it overrides the minority.
Uh, so I will vote for Apple, kept it go for me. So be it.
I had my fun. Maybe I get kicked.
Off the Island. We're going to make this money.
Is the person who is eliminated for round three is layered.
Sorry. I feel bad. I feel bad.
I guess I kind of felt like I was, you know, people were going after me.
So yeah. That's how I expect to be voted off. So yeah.
If the box is green, I think when you win, if the box is red,
it's still in the game and you locked down Apple cat three, two,
one.
Winter. Yes, yes.
Heck yeah, let's go. Yeah, no, it was VR.
You know what? It was?
The mold can raise their hand. Three, two,
one, go ahead.
Wow. All right.
So set. When, uh, you're going after banana, I thought it was so safe.
I was like, it is what it is. Here's what happened. So everybody was super cool.
I wish that I could have been involved in war. I'm sad to get around London,
but you know, it happens. I learned anything from this experience,
no gaming as usual. And we ended up winning. So.
How cool is that? It was so awesome. Seeing two other women in the cast,
if people didn't know that women can be and our pro and our amazing this
episode should teach people something.
For gamers, come in, all shapes and sizes.
But I think the one thing that everyone has in common is the amount of effort
they had to grind up their game to get to where they are.